and this again is one of the best parts
about posit workbench is that no matter
what your data science team uses a
preferred IDE the hope is that we can
support it here within positive
workbench so we currently support
Jupiter notebook Jupiter lab we have the
rstudio IDE as well and then we have the
vs code editor which is a great
all-purpose editor which is what we're
going to use today so I'm going to click
on vs code
and when we do that we get some
additional options so I can give this vs
code session a name I'll just leave it
as a default right here
and then right underneath you're going
to see cluster kubernetes now to tell
you a little bit more about our demo
environment here at posit it is all
hosted in AWS Amazon web services
and it's in a high performance Computing
cluster an HPC environment and that
environment is managed using something
known as kubernetes so some of you may
have heard of kubernetes that's one of
these HPC managers that we support if
you also use slurm we can support that
as well or you can also just run these
tools on a single server that's totally
fine as well
but one of the advantages of using
kubernetes or slurm is you can actually
control this job CPU and memory
allocations so if you just have like a
small job you want to maybe create a
plot or a simple application you can
keep the CPU low keep the memory low and
that's just great for managing compute
resources
but if you have a higher compute a more
demanding job I can bump that up for
example I can change the memory as well
so really good at managing resources
then you'll see this last box right here
and this is the image box so I have the
option to choose a specific Docker image
here to deploy this session so that can
help control additional environment
variables things like what our versions
are available python versions what
packages are installed by default that
can all be controlled using various
stock images but I'll just stick to the
default for right now
that all looks good let's go ahead and
start this session